so look at this this check and that will
be unbelievable
we can even show it
yeah let's just show it that you can't
go king g8 because of rooks yet but now
suddenly this defend we might be seeing
this peter this is on the board by the
way king e8 so you're calling out the
action and he goes backing f5 first
hitting the rook you can also just go to
k4 now no he goes no but rookie seven i
mean okay just just solve this seventh
rank issue and now actually it's a blue
i mean
plug makes this miracle escape because i
think we can already talk about it it's
already basically finished no no
intrigue here
just no intrigue here i mean incredible
safe out of the blue i mean it was i
think already kind of almost designable
position and escapes and he gets a match
i mean he gets the chance to bounce back
amazing stuff i mean finding this whole
sequence of moves which is literally
hanging by a thread and look at this
what a well-earned draw there the
amazing resistance put on by